-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
The White House said yesterday
that it supports
a new bipartisan bill
that would give President Biden
the power to ban TikTok.
Of course, Biden could end
TikTok at any time
simply by making an account.
Ugh, okay.
This jumped the shark.
[ Laughter ]
Capitol Police Chief
Thomas Manger
issued a statement yesterday
criticizing Fox host
Tucker Carlson's release
of security footage
from the January 6th attack
and said Carlson made "offensive
and misleading conclusions."
Of course,
that's just what it says
when you turn on
his closed captioning.
[ Laughter ]
According to newly released
legal documents,
Fox News host Tucker Carlson
told colleagues
after the 2020 election,
"We are very, very close
to being able to ignore Trump
most nights.
I truly can't wait.
I hate him passionately."
Wait, wait, are you telling me
Tucker Carlson
is secretly sane?
[ Laughter ]
I would feel so betrayed
if I was a Fox viewer.
This is like
if you joined a cult,
sold all your belongings,
shaved your head,
moved to the desert,
and then it turns out
the cult leader is just, like...
a Methodist.
[ Laughter ]
Voters in Oklahoma
rejected a measure yesterday
to legalize the recreational use
of marijuana.
Apparently, time already moves
slowly enough in Oklahoma.
[ Laughter ]
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
reportedly sent a letter
to President Biden
requesting that he allow
tennis star Novak Djokovic
to enter the country to play
in the Miami Open tournament.
That story again --
Ron DeSantis begs Biden
to open the border.
[ Laughter ]
After Senator Bernie Sanders
threatened to subpoena him,
Starbucks CEO Howard Schultz
has agreed to testify
before the Senate's
Health, Education, Labor
and Pensions Committee.
And much like a black coffee
from Starbucks,
this has been brewing
for a very long time.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
We talk -- you know,
I'll be honest with you --
behind the scenes,
we talked a little bit.
Like, "Is that joke
gonna work at all?"
And it worked a little.
[ Laughter ]
A venti?
How do you say a little?
-Tall.
[ Laughter ]
That coffee joke
worked a tall.
[ Laughter ]
My callback didn't work a-tall.
You know what?
We're getting there.
We're getting -- We're almost --
We've almost put
a button on this.
Feel like I should have
gotten out a minute ago.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, St--
Oh, boy.
Now there's a follow-up
Starbucks joke.
[ Laughter ]
Way to keep the flow going,
Meyers.
That's right,
Starbucks CEO Howard Schultz
will testify
before a Senate committee
as part of an investigation into
the chain's labor practices.
And while he's there,
they've also got some questions
about those egg bites.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
Tinder recently released
an Australian edition
of its dating dictionary,
which includes the phrase
"kitten fishing."
That means
"changing aspects of yourself
to appear more attractive
to others".
Or, as we call that here,
dating.
[ Light laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.
We're off and running.